then communism or Marxism or socialism or anything
else the Africanism is what they considered to bethe real threat
Yes undoubtedly one of the
major elements of the center of Malcolm X's revolutionary strategy is solidarity the natural
solidarity which must be restored between the
afro-american and his African brother in
their common fight against a common enemy
The organization of afro-american unity sees
the only hope for the black man in America in
a strong Africa and and the necessity of the
afro-american becoming inseparably linked with
the overall program that that's existing on the
African continent the two problems muscles must be
solved together and the two forces must go forward
together and so the organization of afro-american
unity has a program to link the Afro Americans
with the Africans and the Africans with the Afro
Americans when I say Afro Americans I mean those
throughout the entire Western Hemisphere this is
our only hope our hope is in a strong Africa and
when Africa is strong our position in America will
be one of respect but if Africa is weak we will
never be in a position of respect in America I
they used to have a thing that one doesn't have a
Chinaman's chance but they don't say that anymore
they use that expression back when China was weak
but now since Mao Zedong has been successful in
making China a strong country the Chinese have
more chance than anybody else so this thing has
become outdated well just as it took a strong
China to give a Chinese person respect wherever
that Chinese person is found on this earth when
we get a strong Africa at the person of African
origin or African ancestry will be respected
any place on this earth even in America but he
will not be respected in America until Africa is
strong just as the [__] wasn't respected abroad
until China became strong he was the leader who
knew that self-reliance is the only security for
lasting freedom and independence this is why he
rejected the claims for white participation in the
lead of the afro-american freedom movement this
is why he respected the example of the Chinese
people in their revolutionary struggle how did he
view the success of China in developing nuclear
weapons for a defense well I think it's one of the
greatest things that has ever happened because up
until now the nuclear devices have been in the
hands of Europeans they've exercised a monopoly
over the nuclear weapons or over the ability to
produce nuclear weapons but now the Chinese have
even if they equalized it by being successful
by being a non white or non European nation
and at the same time the developing successfully
the ability to produce nuclear weapons so as far
as I'm concerned it was a very good thing and
I do hope that they are able to build bigger
ones and better ones every day because the only
language that the European powers understand is
the language of power and a domination has to
be in a position to talk or speak the language
that these are imperialists understand and China
has developed the ability to be in that position
and as long as she can speak the language that
they understand it's better for the other dark
countries
YES, men like this live always in the
shadow of danger he was born in white America but his vision reaches far beyond his limits it
goes deep into the future of the black man
Today for the first time the black people of the West
are beginning to look homeward they're beginning
to look back toward the mother continent of
Africa and they're gaining spiritual strength
from these roots the African continent is on the
rise the motherland is on the rise and our people
all over the Western Hemisphere are looking back
at this rising continent and the unity of that
continent and it's giving us strength and hope
for the future and for the first time not only
is the black men on the African continent fighting
and seeking and fighting for his place in the Sun
but his fight is putting the same spirit in the
black people in the West and we are also seeking
and fighting for our place in the Sun and we will
not rest until that place has been secured
What's your plan now
I'm going back to the stage
first and see how my family is going unis got a family there and see what developed
In NewYork, on February 21st 1965 brother Malcolm X fell before the bullets of assassin his killers were
those whose interest he knew would crumble before
the irresistible force of worldwide revolution
against racism and dollar ISM those who directed
the murder of our courageous brother demonstrated
their crazy belief that the ideal she fought for
can be killed they are wrong because the voice
of Malcolm X was the voice of our humanity the
words she spoke can never be silenced they are
the words and the determination of his people
a people fighting for their place in the Sun
and will never rest until that place has beensecured
and fighting for our place in the Sun and
we will not rest until that place has been secured